yeah it is wet there's still lashing
rain and rain and quite strong winds
here but nowhere near as bad as it's
been and throughout the early hours of
this morning and certainly yesterday
hurricane Ian has now been downgraded to
a category one storm as expect as it
makes its way across Central and Eastern
Florida but it was Far Far stronger than
that when it made landfill not far from
here actually late yesterday afternoon
bringing with it winds well in excess of
100 miles per hour and it was the water
rather than the wind that people were
fearing here even before the event and
they were proven correct because it
brought with its Storm surges of up to
18 feet in certain places and there are
areas of Fort Myers around five or six
miles from here that are still under
four or five feet of water and we know
that people are still awaiting rescue
the city of Fort Myers writing this
evening on social media that there is
responding to fires extensive flooding
and life-threatening conditions here is
our report on a devastating day for this
part of Southwest Florida that there's
been absolutely catastrophic damage over
a wide part of this Coast of Florida
there's also inevitably been loss of
life as well so this is a secondary
issue but it may become a more important
one there are 2.2 million people in this
area of Florida this evening still
without power they've been without power
for several hours now and it means that
there are families people who are
looking for relatives for friends and
aren't able to make contact with them it
also means that we're not yet getting a
clear picture of the extent of damage in
certain places it's only really when
Dawn breaks that we'll be able to get a
true idea of just what path of
Destruction hurricane Ian has wrought
but it's certainly been a devastating
event a catastrophe week event for this
part of Florida probably the worst the
worst hurricane this particular area has
experienced in terms of damage and one
of the worst hurricanes that's made
landfall anywhere in the United States